[Music]
but i can though
who are you
hi i'm aegis alba
peace
hi
i'm jonathan majors and we'll be
answering
the fans
questions
right here oh a lead bible is that good
all right let's roll
what is your go to song to get the party
started we got dj us dancing this first
really yeah um you know what i'm just
gonna say you know it's uh don't stop to
get enough michael jackson oh my god
that that just hits every time as soon
as you play that break
oh everyone's
you know uh i'ma go with
dmx
oh get it on the floor swiss speech the
swiss beast get on the floor get it get
it on the floor get down my dogs out
again
my brothers
if jonathan mages had a dj name what
would it be oh
uh
uh
i'd call him slim mages
slip mages on the decks
just because you know
you know as his presence is huge but he
doesn't take up much space you know what
i mean he's very um jonathan mages is
very uh
uh low maintenance so that's why i would
call him slim and obviously
majors because of his name but you know
i'm talking about playing major tunes
now you know what i'm saying
yo yo what's up what's up what's up this
is slim majors on the ones and twos bam
yeah what's up what's up what's up we
gonna start off with some dmx let's go
come in with some uh
some some some mj some some michael
jackson majors i like that yeah yeah
yeah
that's my first tattoo
what is your best party trick
um my best party trick is i i can do
these incredible fart sounds
so i'll do it for you guys okay here we
go oh my god
[Music]
gets him every time bro
gets him every time my wife says please
stop doing it so embarrassing
[Music]
it's all good
can you smell it
and it really fires him up
but i can though
it's so realistic is it just elbow this
is 4d fart sounds
whatever it takes good what's yours uh i
don't know if mine is uh
or possible in this mode
let's see i can i can i'm a bubble
machine
a what a bubble machine and and i'm
nervous about it because i don't know if
i'll be able to do it but um i can make
spit bubbles
and i can actually blow them in the air
i guess we should try it yes all right
let's move out of here
pressure
okay
if it could happen let me guess how did
you realize you could do that uh there's
a thing called in-school suspension
it didn't hydrate
if you were to teach jonathan some
british slang what would it be um
mate it's all gone barney rubble
barney rubble if you don't show up on
time it's going to be some barney rubble
you know you say it to me like that i
feel like i'm in rock and roll
and then another one you could say
yeah uh you know jonathan majors in that
film it wasn't his it wasn't his georgie
georgie he's georgie best it means your
best yeah it's nice work yeah can you
put one of them in a sentence
if um
if i don't get this spit bubble out yeah
there's gonna be some body wrap
it's good okay
it's not bad
if you could have a drink with any celeb
dead or alive who would it be um if i if
i could i would have definitely loved to
have met bob marley
and i would just love to sit with that
man and talk about his life works as a
musician but also his philosophy you
know what what's your favorite uh
molly song oh come on man
um all day all night is one of my
favorites do you know that song that's
the georgie
[Laughter]
yes it's the georgie
[Laughter]
this is cool
yeah here we go okay
[Music]
do you prefer playing the hero with the
villain what do you think
[Laughter]
i love playing the villain
maybe because i'm not
maybe because i am